hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einem
video über das spiel monster legends was
mir mega oft in die kommentare
geschrieben würde mir wurde gesagt hey
macht davon vielleicht noch eine kleine
serie
das heißt ich werde hier von jetzt
irgendwie viel biss und panda davon
jetzt irgendwie vier bis zehn bis fünf
weil sie nicht irgendwie so ein paar
videos machen solange mir das spaß macht
weil ich finde solche spiele wo man
wirklich so wie bei irgendwelchen
anderen sachen wie was gibt's da noch
clash of plants oder keine ahnung was
felix am anfang ja interessant aber
danach am ende ist es dann so ein
bisschen abflachen und das möchte ich
einfach herausfinden wie mir das spiel
so gefällt wird aufgeschrieben
ich bin pandev der meister der monster
und ich helfe dir dabei selbst ein
mächtiger meister der monster zu werden
das ist auf jeden fall megacool lass
mich dir zeigt wie du etwas blicke auf
die schaltfläche bauen ok tippe auf die
schaltfläche lebensräumen und kaufe den
lebensraum des feuers in ordnung dann
kaufe ich mir mein lebenstraum des
feuers und setzte den ko
ich möchte ihnen hier okay okay eine
sekunde 0 sekunden
mein lebensraum des feuers hätte ich es
schaffen wir nun ein erstes monster
monster aber auf die schaltfläche
einkaufen
ok und jetzt ich habe vier oder sieht
aus wie sonnen wie sowieso nicht wieso
man das ein bisschen gibt ihre kleinen
arbeitete an diesem so bob der
baumeister mäßig aber so gummibär
wackelt wohin sich auch um den sie in
den einstellungen dass facebook kennwort
für luca thilo ein gut so jeden fall
richtig stark dass jetzt einfach mal mit
einem video mein facebook kennwort
eingeben musste also ich bin bei dem
spiel halt mit facebook angemeldet weil
ich dachte über facebook ist es
einfacher und so
deswegen habe ich mich damit facebook
anmeldet deswegen kann wahrscheinlich
auch gerade geben sie facebook kennen
weil an dieser seite auf facebook das
möchtest du mit deinem neuen 4g so
machen ich möchte gern um endlich möchte
man den platz ihre der monsterwelle das
habitat gebiet und brütet das ei aus die
tat ist sein zuhause
oh mein gott ich will doch näher
heranzoomen dich so knuffig wir jetzt
auf den lebensraum um zu sehen was sich
darin befindet wie es aussieht kann ich
den
füttern rudi hat ihn füttern
ich glaube ist der stufe 4 erreicht ich
habe bluetec sowie dass sich das immer
irgendwie ein bisschen mit pokémon
vergleiche aber ich finde mit monstern
und so ist bei mir einfach pokémons
obwohl es eigentlich komplett anders was
man bei pokémon keine sachen baut was
habe ich jetzt auch einen bauernhof was
machen die damals neue dinosaurier baby
das jetzt in zeit lang keine videos
miteinander kam aber ich habe klausuren
geschrieben und hatte allgemein viel um
die ohren war von morgens bis mittags
weg dann haben leute hier gepennt ganz
einfach arbeit am schreiben und alles
mögliche aber ich habe ein gutes gefühl
also es könnten schon nach 1 oder 2 oder
so ein paar dabei sein wird es
interessiert euch gar nicht aber nur
deswegen kam hat keine videos clique dem
bauernhof an und wähler an wohnungen zu
bauen kann ich jetzt einfach so freunde
ich glaube ich habe den den sinn des
spiels schon mal grob verstanden ich
habe quasi bauernhöfe die produziert
mehr essen wenn ich kämpfe mache kriege
ich auch essen und dieses essen kann ich
dann wieder die dinosaurier stecken
damit die höher werden vom level an
kämpfen mehr leute und so weiter und war
ein blauer accenture hans ist nun reif
für die ernte tippe auf sammeln um ihn
zu ernten mal blaue axxom schwanz man
man man ja viel erfolg danke ach das
kann ich irgendwie jetzt wieso bin ich
dann hallo e mail
nee ich würde ich hier im facebook hallo
was soll das denn jetzt bei einem kann
ich nicht jetzt irgendwie ich möchte ein
weg ja ok mache einfach mein gott mit
facebook
ich bin einfach nur total behindert also
wir können allerdings auch ziele klicken
so wie ich das jetzt nicht verstanden
und jetzt haben wir die ziele kreuzfeuer
und natur monster zucht experimente
werden die die aufregendsten ergebnisse
bringen
das neue leykauf wir kaufen jetzt einen
für 400 wir haben das glück jetzt aus
und wir haben einen trailer ich
bescheuert
wer zwei von denen oder das ist gar
nicht so cool ich habe außerdem zwei von
denen jetzt na gut das ist auf jeden
fall schon mal sinnvoll ach komm ich
muss hier auf züchten klicken jetzt
nehme ich hier den giebel und ich nehme
die mimo manchmal auf die jetzt züchten
geht meine liebe jungs macht man jetzt
hier
das kann er nicht so lange dauern bei
euch oder nicht ich glaube jetzt hier
einfach grad schon jeden fall weil die
gerade einfach mal die sind immer noch
am liebe machen was ist denn los mit dem
hier kann es rein theoretisch sein dass
ich einfach wie lange dauert der
beschleunige das ausschöpfen von feuer
natur ach ich kann jetzt machen wir das
mal anders und zwar jetzt einfach mal
hier drauf gehen auf züchten und jetzt
nehmen nämlich hier den mimo und hallo
jetzt nämlich den gebieten und hier die
mühle und jetzt geht hat nämlich auch
mal jetzt jedoch warte die kunden
weitere beschreibung das natürlich und
jetzt haben wir ein neues dann lag es
nicht am spiel sondern es lag einfach
daran dass ich versucht habe sein level
4 monster mit einem level 1 monster zu
fahren und das ging dann wohl irgendwie
gerade nicht kriegen auch die ziele und
beschleunige das ganze jetzt ihren
bettchen da ausrufen
das war sechs sekunden tt was möchte mit
dem green ist das grüne ge alter als ob
das linkem ein monster ist jetzt wie
krass ich habe einfach ein grünes okay
dann muss natürlich erst mal hochpumpen
aber ich würde sagen jetzt bevor wir
diese ziele machen wir mal jetzt im netz
auf 100 video ebenen kampf auf der
abendkarte mal kurze frage meine beiden
monster gegen den grossen da verpacke
ich doch wartet dass es die erinnert
mich tatsächlich an alte zeiten und
claudio das ist halt echt wie pokemon so
ein bisschen da mache ich mit ihm hier
sengende drohte auf den hier barbaren
barmen bruder und gewonnen
wenn ich die beiden jetzt auch auf
bisasam und um commander um teilen
könnten
bla bla dann wäre auf dem richtig cool
eine ausdauer ist voll okay stark ich
könnte jetzt rein theoretisch und
zweiten kampf machen aber dieses video 8
core mein kampf geht noch an barbara
gegen zappos.com kämpfen
jetzt mache ich hier auf diesem flug
pokémon haben natürlich initiative und
können deswegen er angreifen aber das
ist jetzt glaube ich schon zuviel
pokémon was ich einfach rein bringen du
geht erst mal hier auf den hier darauf
machte prinz platz nimmt sie davon die
hälfte von einer kappe wenn dann nimmt
er hier natürlich senken betonte das ist
eine wahrhaft vielleicht auf den anderen
vorgegeben sollen ich mach mal
gegenstände habe ich die liebe
da kann ich mir wahrscheinlich auch von
lebens tränke rund wie bei pokémon super
trank oder so bin ich bitte euch ich bin
doch so locker wie hier gleich mit
vereine sieht einfach genauso aus wie
zapf junge es sieht einfach exakt so aus
aber dann gewonnen ist stark und wir
haben ein neues level erreicht ja die
beiden sind level verhuven brauche ich
bin richtig stolz auf uns aber das würde
ich sagen war es dann erstmal für das
erste video ich habe jetzt quasi dieses
dieses tutorial euch so ein bisschen
gezeigt weil ich das spiel damit euch
zusammen bisschen anfangen wollte ich
habe euch was hab ich dann noch mit euch
gebracht wir haben jetzt aber komme ich
hab 250 goldie haben heute zusammen
tutorial gespielt wir haben einen kampf
gemacht wir haben poker monster
gezüchtet und wir haben komische
probleme mit facebook gehabt aber ich
würde sagen das war's erst mal mit
diesem video von moslems wenn ihr
eventuell ein zweites oder drittes oder
viertes oder fünftes video haben wollt
dann würde ich dir einfach mal
wöchentlich samstags
laden oder so in eine andere stadt oder
so schreibt es mir in die kommentare
zeigt mit der bewertung downloadlink es
in der beschreibung und natürlich habe
ich auf facebook twitter instagram dem
anderen